look Ben I don't appreciate your callous
attitude okay yeah really okay
you may hold my fate in your hands like
a small bird
but I still think you're an ass
you want to get a beer
10 30 in the morning yeah you seem like
you can use a beer let's get a beer well
have you ever been part of a government
body before uh I have yeah
a small town called Partridge Minnesota
why does that sound familiar
you're Benji Wyatt I am oh my God you
are so cute oh well thank you what was
that song you played at the swearing-in
ceremony there it is
can I talk to you sure what are you
doing here I'm just confirming a
suspicion I had what are you talking
about I had nothing to do with this date
they're both so beautiful they probably
just want to see each other naked okay
well I know what you're trying to do and
you're not that good at being sneaky yes
I am no you're not I'm great at being
sneaky clearly you're not oh hey hey
there
I got you uh some waffles here courtesy
of JJ's Diner and chicken soup courtesy
of meat I'll take the waffles thank you
so how did the rest of the meeting go
um well you said you needed 80 total
businesses to participate yeah we have
110. and Counting
so uh nice work Leslie
we're to you too oh uh left the chicken
soup there just in case it's a
old Family Recipe it's not a big deal
but
thank you for that okay
Leslie nope gets as many favors as she
needs
can I ask why
because she's the kind of a person who
uses favors to help other people
and also my buddy Dave was the crankiest
bastard in the department until he
started dating Wesley
so she
okay are they still dating or
no
move to San Diego a year ago
was it a serious thing or
what do you care you pervert nope nope
I'm all good
um everything's fine
this is fine
foreign hey sorry about the whole mess
crisis has been averted so let's go talk
to the chief oh I already talked to him
they'll give us the hours we need no
problem
great what a relief yeah
hey are you hungry I haven't eaten you
don't
you know the great calzone place over in
idiot Bill oh really down terrible idea
Avenue okay Ben White bankrupts the town
and then comes to Pawnee to tell us how
to spend our money there's no story here
Shawna he's just a dedicated civil
servant who's doing whatever he can to
make sure that this is the best Harvest
Festival ever
and he's easy on the eyes too
um what is the nature of your
relationship with strictly professional
just friends so are you colleagues are
you friends we are colleagues with
benefits
we're colleagues who benefit from the
fact that we're also friends hey hey
um so somebody I don't want to say who
is totally me God sweetums to donate
another 15 cotton candy machines ah take
that curse take that curse
bazooka
that's funny get a room
okay ice town was a disaster and it
seems like it was probably your fault
and what I can tell you mismanaged the
hell out of it wow why even say that
already the point is this project this
is as much yours as it is mine it's ours
and it's gonna be really great and I'm
glad you're here thank you
I was actually coming to see you I
wanted your advice on something oh yeah
my boss in Indianapolis he wants me back
on the road in a week but then this
morning Chris offered me a job to stay
here in Pawnee work for him
do you want to do that
well I don't know am I moving around so
much the past few years it might be nice
to stay in one place for a while
what do you think
you should stay
don't go back to Indianapolis
stay here you think yeah yes
it's a great City here you know and
there are great people and you've made a
lot of friends yeah what are you gonna
do you go back to your old job and hack
up people's budgets
stay here
help us build something I already
accepted the job
I'm I'm staying here
that's good yeah I think so
um
so I have some ideas for the health
initiative oh okay how about I swing by
later and we'll just you know go over
everything or we could go out after work
you know go to JJ's or something grab a
bite
um I don't I don't think I can but why
don't we just talk about it later in
this building
okay all right but uh You're great and
you have great ideas and
uh
uh uh bye
I just wanted to make sure that there
were no hard feelings after I forced you
to break up with Tom oh we were
no no hard feelings because just real
Bugaboo of mine and it applies to
everyone just the other day Ben told me
that he might want to socialize with
somebody from the government and I said
I'm sorry not possible really
did he say who
good morning Ben oh
sorry sorry did I scare you no I just
wanted to remind you of the art show
that's happening tonight at the
community center great well that sounds
cool that sounds like uh something that
will be a big success you know
I mean like everything that you uh that
you put your your your paws on your
fingers
oh hi hi I was at a meeting around the
corner and some people wanted to destroy
this painting so I brought it here
where's Andy in April they're out
shopping
what are you doing here I
moved into the spare room
really
yeah huh can I come in yeah yeah sure of
course
why do they want to destroy it well it's
a painting of me
as a centaur
okay and it's a nude
oh just basically like the chestal
region mostly
you don't have to look at it if you
don't want to I don't know it's very
classy yeah no I'm sure it is you're a
level-headed person what do I do here
well I don't know I mean it is one of
the basic rules of government that you
shouldn't offend people yeah
I guess you're right I just
so annoyed
by all these rules lately I'm back here
um hey you're nice
I can see why she likes you
when did she
likes me God this is so high school just
rent a limo ask her to the prom I'm sure
she'll say yes all right
thank you for that year-over-year
maintenance cost analysis that was that
was really helpful you're so welcome I
was thinking about you when I wrote it
because I was um
because I told you I wanted to read it
yeah it's a good reason oh anyway Chris
wants to see us in his office I guess we
should head over there all right all
right all right cool great see you there
I'll see you there Benjamin Ben all
right Leslie man Leslie
hi Ben
oh hey Ann
the Granville Hotel and Spa they have
the softest house oh I gotta tell you I
love a nice towel to my life I mean it's
the simplest luxury but it makes all the
difference their bath mats are amazing
it's like stepping on
foreign
oh hold on
eyelash on your face I got it
make a wish learning to speak Mandarin
unit three get away from me sorry I'm
just getting around I'm
I'm allergic to fingers where are you
going
China
you were really great in our
presentation today oh nice I like the
stuff you said about Pawnee that was
really nice to hear
plenty is a really special town I love
living there
and um
and I look forward to the moments of my
day where I
where I get to hang out with the town
and talk to the town about stuff and the
town has really nice belong to here too
and he's read a shocking number of
political biographies for a town which I
like
oh God I'm sorry and I know we can get
into trouble but I I
I can't take this anymore and I feel
like we have to at least talk about it
I mean it's not just me right
no
that's nice to you
uh
well
sorry I keep myself very well hydrated
and my bladder is the size of a thimble
I urinate roughly 12 times a night
I think I might go to bed too actually
oh yeah
okay
um
well look
good job again today
really yeah
yeah Chris showed up because I wasn't
thinking clearly I love my job Ben loves
his job and it's just not worth the risk
hey Chris just wanted me to drop off
these receipts oh well he's not here he
took off
oh